have you guys ever had to ride in an
ambulance no yeah i did like in japan
actually in japan yeah because like
aki's like aki had a like slight
accident right at that last place and uh
like it was pretty bad so like we had to
call the hospital and i was riding the
hospital right in the hospital right
running in the hospital
i had to get an ambulance so i was
running the ambulance late at night and
like because it was late at night the
closest hospital was closed right makes
no [ __ ] sense like you think
hospitals are open all the time yeah uh
so we had to go to like the next pho
this one so it was like a 15 20 minute
ride yeah um and uh luckily you know
like aki was okay like she was calming
down in the ambulance right and uh it
was so [ __ ] up because it's like in my
head during that whole ambulance ride
like 95 percent of my brain was like oh
god i hope you know ugly's okay and sure
you know we'll be able to get out of
this yeah yeah yeah and five percent of
my brand was like oh [ __ ] yeah i'm in an
ambulance
like whoa this is so cool i've never
been a one before this is what it looks
like oh [ __ ]
i i always just feel really bad i feel
like i'm inconveniencing these workers
yeah even though even though it's their
job yeah like i could my leg could be
broken i'm like [ __ ] i'm so sorry for
wasting your time yeah actually someone
else has a heart attack or something
yeah like i'm sure i can get that myself
it's all right that's called an uber
it's just a little maneuver right it's
just like when you're i remember i was
in the emergency room i've never been in
the emeralds by the way but i was in the
emergency room and this guy was just
holding on to his thumb i thought that
was really [ __ ] weird and he was
really calm yeah he was holding on to
his thumb like this and his i could see
that holding on to his thumb like his
thumb was falling off his thumb had been
cut off and he was holding on all like
in his hand he was holding onto his
thumb what and he was like really calm
and they were talking to him being like
are you ready mr jones to go to the yeah
and he was like yeah it's all right
i don't mind waiting a little bit it's
really weird
it's really strange because i didn't
realize what he was doing at first until
i like saw the bag of ice with it and
then he had a band-aid going around like
this and his hand was like like this
right like and he had like bandage going
around oh i just i just wanted him to be
like are you ready mr jones if you like
thumbs up haha
it's really weird i i've you know i was
like tv shows in the uk like like just
farmers who like had their arm like cut
off
whatever
because like if there's one finger you
don't want to leave you don't want to
you don't want to do right you don't
want to freak out you want to be calm
that's true i feel like the more you
panic the worse is for everyone so
you're like calm yourself down but i
don't know it's easier said than done
yeah i mean obviously like we've never
i've never been in that situation so
it's hard to like imagine how you'd
react in that situation because you've
kind of never been in that situation
yeah it's weird really because when i've
been in situations where i i feel like i
have to calm myself down afterwards i'm
like is that what you know you see
people like freaking out yeah are they
like trying to calm themselves down or
like what's going through their heads
what do you mean like when when i'm like
let's say like uh if i'm bleeding really
badly which has happened a few times or
something and i have hemophilia and my
my whole focus when i when it's happened
i remember distinctly is like i'm
literally just focusing on not freaking
out that's all i did yeah
and i'm like i'm like trying to keep it
together yeah i just think like i'm like
is that what everyone does i don't know
because there's no way to get into
someone else's mind right now
so i wonder like
when some has anything ever happened to
you where you're like really scared and
you're like freaking out probably not
like i've never had anything like life
threatening or anything like that so i i
wouldn't know myself how i would react
but
if it's
if if i know how i react with a lot of
situations it's just
yeah calm
yeah it's like trying to force yourself
i don't know how to i don't know how the
the human mind is really [ __ ] weird
yeah i don't know like i'm like i i'm
the kind of guy who in stressful
situations just say nothing like i don't
know like
okay this is going off tangent now but
like i don't i don't physically react
when like someone tries to try to jump
scare me a lot of the times right i
remember i remember like every time
there's a jump scare or anytime sydney
like tries to like prank jump scare me
like i like she goes ah like that or
something when i come out the shower or
whatever and i'm and i'm just like
completely like [ __ ] the terminator
zero reaction and she's just like [ __ ]
you and i'm like haha sydney that's
right i ain't a [ __ ] [ __ ] whereas
whereas inside i'm just like [ __ ] my
life you know like inside i'm like
screaming my [ __ ] heart out man so
like
i am the complete opposite like i hate
it when someone comes around the corner
and like scares me like i always stop
myself from like throwing a fist out
because i'm like it's a threat oh no
it's not it's not okay thank god
my final flight is just like fight no no
no no okay i shouldn't i shouldn't no
but like but it's weird because when i
had to call the ambulance for rocky i
was like surprisingly calm i thought i
was gonna be because i'd never like
called the ambulance before right or
like you know because i didn't know what
the [ __ ] the procedure was right so the
first time i was calling i was in my
head i was like oh god what the [ __ ] am
i gonna say am i gonna start uh you know
what the hell's gonna happen but then by
the time i got finished i was like oh
that i was a lot calmer than i thought
domino's will be here in 15 minutes
honey don't worry about it i'm gonna
call the ambulance now oh [ __ ]
i'm sorry
oh you said ambulance oh [ __ ] probably
said pepperoni
don't
yeah it was surprisingly calming but
then i think it was for me i'm calm in
the moment but then when it's all over
that's when it all comes out yeah yeah
right so
to me i panic like post when everything
just kind of sinks in to be like holy
[ __ ] that [ __ ] happened yeah i went
through all this [ __ ] and it's only
after the event has transpired that it
actually starts to sink in and i start
to feel the gravity of everything that's
happened yeah yeah at least to me